[Musik]
mehr als 100 tage krieg in der ukraine
und weiter kein ende in sicht hauptziel
der russischen offensive der donbass
schwere zerstörungen zeugen von den
erbitterten kämpfen der letzten tage in
einer pressekonferenz spricht ukraines
präsident salewski von intensiven
kämpfen der feind seit zahlenmäßig
überlegen und starke winde
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
mit einer kurzen bestandsaufnahme zur
lage in der ukraine
die nachfolgenden sendungen verschieben
sich um elf minuten nach
wie vor wird unerbittlich gekämpft
besonders im osten der ukraine
die russischen angreifer sind dort in
den letzten wochen vorangekommen gegen
zellen widerstand und deutlich langsamer
als geplant wer kontrolliert noch was in
der ukraine
isabell kemmner über den aktuellen stand
das russische militär verstärkt im don
was weiter seine angriffe mit
zusätzlichen kampfflugzeugen und
hubschraubern schwer unter beschuss die
stadt ließ mit dem benachbarten sierra
oder und jetzt ist sie derzeit wohl zum
hauptziel der russischen offensive
geworden
russlands verteidigungsminister sergej
schoigu meldet sich heute zu wort und
verkündet siegesmeldungen ein
beträchtlicher teil der volksrepublik in
donetsk und lohans am linken ufer des
erwerbs quito netz wurde befreit
darunter die städte klassenklima und
schwer togos sowie 15 weitere besiedelte
orte
und so schulte weiter die von russischen
truppen eingenommenen helfen mario pohl
und badlands seien wieder bereit für
getreide lieferungen
die kämpfe im osten des landes sind
weiter heftig viele ortschaften sind
hier wohl schon weitgehend unter
russische kontrolle
zerstörungen in der ukrainischen stadt
bach mut die häuser von raketen und
artillerie zerschossen es gibt kein gas
in manchen häusern auch keinen strom und
kein wasser brot muss aus umliegenden
ortschaften gebracht werden
heute wurden wir aus einem flugzeug
bombardiert die fenster haben gewackelt
und wir haben am ganzen körper gezittert
im rathaus versucht man die versorgung
der stadt sicherzustellen
im augenblick bemühen wir uns die stadt
zu schützen weil wir unter feuer stehen
und wir müssen fast jeden tag das gas
und wasser system wieder herstellen
und auch das ist eine meldung von heute
die separatisten in der region bonn
jetzt bestätigen den tod des russischen
generals roman kultur er wäre damit wohl
der vierte general russlands der
gefallen ist und
in washington begrüße ich markus kaim
der das kriegsgeschehen intensiv
beobachtet erkannt welche ziele hat denn
putin mit diesem krieg bisher erreicht
und welcher nicht
das ist nicht so ganz einfach zu
beurteilen weil am anfang gab es sehr
klare sehr groß angelegte ziele die
besetzung der ukraine ihre
neutralisierung eine neue regierung wie
wir längst wissen ist davon nicht viel
übrig geblieben und das problem ist dass
seitdem
politischer ziele nicht mehr klar
benannt worden sind wir sehen
militärische operationen die fokussieren
auf den osten aber die damit verbundenen
politischen ziele sind nicht klar ob
russland diese gebiete dauerhaft
annektieren will ob das eine
verhandlungsmasse ist in
friedensverhandlungen oder anderes mehr
darüber hat sich präsident putin
ausgestiegen da können wir nur
spekulieren
die ukraine soll ja von mehreren
westlichen staaten auch von den usa mit
schweren waffen unterstützt werden kann
dass das blatt noch einmal entscheidend
wenden
davon ist auszugehen es ist jetzt ein
zeitfenster von sechs bis acht wochen in
dem die russen die russischen und die
sowjetischen waffen die im moment in der
ukraine sind die aus osteuropäischen
staaten in die ukraine verbracht worden
sind verbraucht werden dann sind sie
kaputt unbenutzbar es keine munition
und dann tut sich eine lücke auf und in
diese lücke hinein müssten die
westlichen kaufen lieferung von sechs
bis acht wochen
und wenn das erfolgt dann hat die
ukraine eine gute chance weiter zu
bestehen wenn nicht könnte sich das
kriegs blatt zu ihren gunsten wenden sie
selbst sind ja gerade in washington wie
sieht denn der amerikanische strategie
hier aus in bezug auf die ukraine
es gibt vier erklärte kriegsziele das
erste ist ein reputationsgewinn für
präsident putin im bereich der
außenpolitik nach dem afghanistan ist
aus und die saas aus dem vergangenen
jahr das zweite ist eine stärkung der
nato dies erreicht worden zur ukraine
krise aber über die ukraine hinaus das
dritte ist eine dauerhafte sprechen
russlands dem ziel dienen die sanktion
und die militärische operation russland
soll ausgeschaltet werden als welt
politischer rivale und das vierte ist
eine abschreckung auf alle anderen
akteure die ähnliche operation vorhaben
das sagt man nicht so deutlich aber der
ist vor allen dingen tiere gedacht und
dieter anfrage vielen dank für das
gespräch nach geschenken
sehr gerne
zu den unmittelbaren folgen des krieges
gehört auch dass millionen tonnen
getreide nicht exportiert werden kann
weil russland ukrainische häfen
blockiert die ukraine gilt als
kornkammer europas fällt sie als
lieferant aus hat das dramatische folgen
bis hin zu hungersnöten in ärmeren
regionen der welt über korridor in
schwarzen mehrere zwar verhandelt bis
jetzt aber müssen agrarprodukte mühsam
per zug oder lastwagen ausgeführt werden
alissa jung hat sich das angesehen
lkw an lkw so sieht es zurzeit an der
ukrainisch polnischen grenze medica
genie aus acht kilometer stau tage
langes warten für die fahrer die
eigentlich getreide ausliefern sollen
sowie cisco hier koche ich hier schlafe
ich hier mache ich alles wie normale
leute auch nur mit weniger platz
was am meisten zeit kostet sind die
veterinär kontrollen an der grenze wie
in polen
die ukraine kein eu land erst erzählt
uns saß co
das ganze prozedere geht nur sehr
langsam am ende habe ich 13 tage
gebraucht um die grenze von der ukraine
nach polen zu überqueren
seit die häfen gesperrt sind muss das
getreide über die straße oder schiene
raus doch die wege sind weit und
gefährlich der sprit knapp
immer wieder werden bahnschienen zum
ziele russische angriffe ukraine würden
diese schnell repariert das problem
fehlende logistik an der grenze die
schienen in der ukraine sind breiter als
in der eu das corpus umgeladen werden
diese bauern suchen nun selbst
fieberhaft nach lösungen
weder auf der ukrainischen noch auf der
polnischen seite gibt es entsprechende
terminals manchmal gibt es nur einen
einzigen verladekran selbst wenn der
waggon auf ukrainischer seite beladen
wurde muss er in polen wieder abgeladen
werden wie so oft seit dem krieg werden
sie nun kreativ und beladen züge selbst
für colonia und fahrer wie cisco ist der
10 prozess nur schwer zu verstehen man
sollte die selben regeln die in der eu
anwenden das würde so viel schneller
gehen wenn wir keine grenzkontrollen
hätten 20 millionen tonnen getreide
müssen aus der ukraine herausgebracht
werden bevor die neue ernte eingeholt
wird sonst ist auch diese verloren
in odessa begrüße ich die
kulturstaatsministerin claudia roth die
als erstes mitglied der bundesregierung
die stadt besucht seit kriegsbeginn frau
roth was haben sie erlebt indes er was
erzählen ihnen die menschen die sie
treffen
wir haben eine stadt erlebt die
natürlich ein großer sorge ist vor einem
möglichen angriff
russlands den odessa ist ja ein
strategisch sehr sehr wichtiger ort mit
einem extrem wichtigen hafen für die
ukraine wie gleichzeitig erleben wir
eine stadt voller offenheit voller
herzlichkeit voller menschen wie sie und
ich die kämpfen für das was auch unsere
werte sind für freiheit für den frieden
und für die demokratie sie haben es
gerade angedeutet nach mehr als 100
tagen krieg gibt es dennoch so etwas wie
normalität in odessa
sie spüren an jeder ecke dass krieg ist
ja sie sehen wir sehen ganz ganz viele
häuser wichtige orte wie die oper hier
im hintergrund die mit sandsäcken
barrique addiert ist fenster die
geschützt werden es gab auch hier schon
einschlägige mit toten und zwar an
zivilen orten wie einer jugendherberge
wie einem privathaus wie einem friedhof
also der krieg ist präsent und natürlich
haben ganz viele menschen verwandte
freunde in den kampfgebieten und haben
auch glaube ich schon sehr viel schmerz
und trauer erleben müssen wie gefährdet
sind denn kunst und kultur durch diesen
krieg
grund meiner reise war ja die einladung
des ukrainischen kulturministers weil
dieser krieg ist auch ein krieg gegen
die kultur es ist der versuch der
versuch der systematischen zerstörung
der kulturellen identität über
375 kultureinrichtungen orte
konzertsaal konzertsäle theater sind
angegriffen sind zerstört worden über
135 kirchen vor allem orthodoxe kirchen
sind angegriffen beschädigt zerstört
worden das ist wirklich der
systematischen versucht die kultur
anzugreifen und die kultur kunst nur das
wurde mir hier jetzt nochmal
überdeutlich ist die stimme der
demokratie und deswegen tun wir sehr gut
daran alles dafür zu tun um
kulturgutschutz zu bewahren vielen dank
für das gespräch frau roth nach odessa
ich danke ihnen in der ferne
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet wenn sie den menschen in
der ukraine helfen wollen können sie das
tun beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe stichwort zdf nothilfe
ukraine bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 alle infos auch unter spenden zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
das war unser zdf spezial vielen dank
für ihr interesse und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]